翻訳: Toshihiro Suzuki
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
T44
これが何を意味するものか
皆さんご存じでしょうか？
知っているという方は
手を挙げてみてください
ありがとうございました
思っていたよりもいて
僕自身すごいびっくりしました
これはパラリンピックの陸上競技における
僕の障害区分を表したクラス分けの数字です
今回のリオデジャネイロパラリンピックでは
これまで以上に
メディアの方に取り上げていただいたので
知っている方も
少しずつ増えてきてるのではないかと思います
T は陸上のトラックを意味し
100メートル、リレー、マラソンといった
走る種目
だということを表しています
これは障害区分を表しています
僕のような片足の膝から下を切断した選手
そして片足の足首の機能がマヒした選手
だということを表しています
このようにパラリンピックでは
競技の公平性を保つために
障がいの種類や程度に応じて
細かくクラス分けというものがされています
そして オリンピックと同様に
障がいのあるアスリートが
頂点を目指し
日々練習に取り組んでいます
頂点に立ちたい という思いでは
オリンピックとパラリンピック
この二つに違いはありません
現在の日本では
障がい というものに
触れる機会が少なく
まだ慣れていないためか
いい方にも悪い方にも
どこか過敏に反応してしまう
そんな雰囲気があるように感じます
一方で
科学技術が進歩し
失ったり
不足した分を
補うことで
障がいのある方も健常に近い状態で
生活することができるようになっています
将来 健常者と障がい者
この二つの距離
今よりもずっと近くなるでしょう
もしかしたら ある分野においては
障がい者の方が健常者よりも
優れた能力を発揮すること
があるかもしれません
皆さん 障がい とは何でしょうか？
今日はそういったことを
一緒に考える時間にできたらなと思います
僕は 生まれた時から右足がなかった
というわけではありません
15歳の時に
ユーイング肉腫
という悪性腫瘍が発病し
治療のために 自分の意志で
右足の膝から下
を切断する決意をしました
足を切ると決めた時
そして 足をなくした時
不思議とそこまで悲観しませんでした
本当に自分の足がなくなる
ということに実感できず
これから起こることが
どこか他人事のような
感じがしていたからです
そして何よりも
義足というものを履けば
すぐにこれまで通りの
普通の生活ができると信じていたからです
いざ 義足をつけたとき
歩くことはおろか
立つこともできませんでした
うわぁ 人生終わった
子どもながらにそう思いました
いろんな事ができなくなるんじゃないか
という悲壮感と
他人と違う ということが
何かいけない事のような気がして
自分の障がい
義足というものを隠そうとしていました
夏でもずっと
長ズボンを履いていました
最初は障がいというものを
受け入れることができなかったのです
そんな落ち込んでいた僕に
大きな転機が訪れます
陸上競技との出会いです
高校入学後に
リハビリを兼ねて走ることを始めました
昔は長距離とか大嫌いだったはずなのに
その時 素直に
走れることが嬉しい
と感じました
走る
という
そんな当たり前のことを嬉しいと思うなんて
健常者として生きていた時には
全く感じることのない気持ちでした
高校２年生の時に 記念にと
静岡県の障がい者の陸上大会に参加しました
ここで義足のパラリンピアンの
山本篤選手
春田純選手
この２名のパラリンピアンと出会います
彼らの姿というのは
義足を隠そうとしていた僕と違って
義足を見てくれ
といわんばかりの堂々とした姿でした
彼らの姿を見ていると
義足が恥ずかしいんじゃなくて
義足を隠そうとしている自分自身が
すごい格好悪いな
というふうに感じるようになり
これが義足を受けいれる
大きなきっかけとなりました
それから 山本選手 春田選手と共に練習し
試合を重ねていく中で
僕も彼らのように
本格的にパラリンピックを目指したい
と思うようになり
陸上競技の強い大学へと進学しました
大学在学中は
多くの仲間に支えられ
共に成長することができ
2012年のロンドンパラリンピック
日本代表メンバーとして選ばれ
出場することができました
個人種目では予選落ち
そしてリレーでも４位という結果でしたが
自分が本気で目指した
パラリンピックという舞台に立ったことは
自分の中で とても大きなものとなりました
そして今回の
リオデジャネイロパラリンピック
100メートルでは日本記録を更新し
２走を務めた4×100メートルリレーでは
銅メダルを獲得することができました
（拍手）
しかし これはまだ通過点です
本番は2020年の
東京パラリンピック
さらに上を目指します
右足を失くした当初は
障がいを受け入れられなかった
義足を隠そうとしていた とお話ししました
あれから10年たった今
僕は 大きく変化しています
今では
周囲の視線というものは全く気にせず
こうして普通に短パンも履いて
街にも出ています
日常生活においても全く支障もなく
自分自身でも義足であるということを
忘れてしまうくらいです
そして陸上競技に出会い
日本代表として選ばれ
パラリンピックにも出場することができました
今回はメダルを取ることもできました
健常者として生きていたら なんて
比べることができるものではありませんが
健常者として生きていたら
こんな舞台には立つことは
できなかったでしょう
失ったものがある分
幸せを体験し 幸せを感じる部分が
増えてきたのかなというふうに感じています
苦は楽の種
これは僕が入院中
とても励みにしていた言葉です
今は辛くてもそれを乗り越えれば
必ずいい事が待っている
そう思うと
とても前向きな気持ちになれました
障がい者スポーツの
大きな特徴のひとつに
障がい者スポーツは
一人でやるものではありません
個人種目 団体競技
という意味ではなく
義足や車椅子といった
障がいを補う道具を作ってくれる方々も
参加しているということです
リオデジャネイロパラリンピックでも
実際に履きましたが
僕は今 日本の義足メーカーの
サポートを受けています
僕たちの目標は
健常者と遜色なく走り
そして 超えること
義足がただ歩くためだけの代用品だった時には
そんなこと 考えられませんでした
しかし もしかしたらできるんじゃないか
と思うぐらいまで技術は進歩しています
もし 100メートルにおいて
義足の選手が健常者よりも速く走ったら
皆さんはどう思いますか？
走るのに特化した義足を使っていて
それずるいじゃん とか思ったりしますか？
そういったことも考えないといけない日が
もう すぐそばまで来ているのかなと思います
最初に皆さんに 障がいとは？
と問いかけました
僕の話を聞いて
頭のなかに これまでと違う何か
思い浮かべていただけましたでしょうか
皆さんから見て
今ここに立っている僕は
健常者ですか？
それとも
障害者ですか？
もし僕が長ズボンを履いて
普通に道を歩いていたら
道行く人は誰も僕のことを
右足のない障がい者だとは気付かないでしょう
むしろ 走る という行為においては
この会場の誰よりも
僕は得意かもしれません
日常生活においても
これって障がいなのか そうではないのか
と言うものが 溢れているように感じます
足がない人は障がい者
では 足腰が弱くなったり
怪我をして杖をついて歩いている人は
障がい者でしょうか？
目が見えない人は障がい者
では近視や老眼で
眼鏡をかけないと生活できない人は
眼鏡を取った時
障がい者になるのでしょうか？
誰もが年を取り
これまで できていたことができなくなった時
それは障がい者といえるのでしょうか？
こうしてみると 実は
障がいか そうではないのか
というものの区別自体
難しくなってきてるのかなと思います
いやむしろ そこに明確な線引きをする
必要はないのかもしれません
何かを失うことは辛いことです
特にそれが身体の一部だったら
尚更でしょう
でも 失ったり 不足した分だけ
今までになかった新しい何かを
付け加えることができるようになると
僕は思っています
僕は右足を失いました
でも 足を失ったことで
陸上競技に出会い
本気で目指す目標を見つけ
多くの人と出会い
そして今日も
皆さんとお会いすることができました
足がある時と足がない時の生活
どっちがいい
なんて
比べられるものではないのかもしれませんが
間違いなく言えることは
今とても楽しい日々を
過ごすことができています
人生はプラスマイナスゼロ
になっているんじゃないか
いやむしろ
プラスの部分が多いのかなと思います
最初に皆さんに 障がいとは何か？
と問いかけました
僕自身もまだその答えというものは
見付けることができません
皆さんも同じかと思います
もしかしたらそこには明確な答えというものは
ないのかもしれません
しかし
これからも一緒に
そのことを考えていきましょう
そうすることが
健常者も障がい者も誰もが
生きやすい社会を
作っていくと 僕は信じています
（拍手）